[Musique]
à faire pâlir tous les marquis de sade
[Applaudissements]
à faire rougir les [ __ ] de la barre
[Musique]
à faire crier grâce à tous les échos
à faire trembler les murs de
je et aimé
je vais
de mon état
mais
je
pour
[Musique]
quand j'étais petit garçon je refasse cb
dessous
en chantant
et bien des années plus tard je chasse
et mai
en chantant
c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant de
parler du mauvais temps
en chantant
et c'est tellement mignon de secret
retraité de coûts
en chansons
[Musique]
finalement c'est moi il espérait en
chantant
[Musique]
c'est un cri c'est un champ c'est aussi
la douleur et le sang
tout et fureur qu'elles portent les
acteurs des hommes la part du ciel mais
toutes les portes
du nord
cette bouée au vent
mais là aussi pour les
un peu quand même
puis la jeune loire
du golan at elle atterri vers c'est le
décor du connemara
ce n'est pas du sang
qui coule dans nos veines
c'est la rivière de notre enfance
se déploie sa mort
ce qui me fait de la peine
c'est de voir compères qui danse
[Musique]
la comédie musicale
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue
l'avantagé de la coupe et de chansons
les gens les connaissent par coeur
franchement alors vous êtes très jeune
sardou c'était une évidence et depuis
tout petit vous connaissez les gens sont
pas forcément on a toujours en train de
parler de serge gallardo
c'est une référence alors moi j'ai
entendu parler du projet il ya sept ans
c'était un gros gros projet alors
raconté un peu l'histoire vous partez
vous êtes serein sur un bateau sur le
france évidemment les teams bande de
copains il va se passer des différentes
choses des aventures les armes on tombe
amoureux s'il sort de la vie et il ya
tous les tubes de faire beau
il est
évidemment bien vous restitue bas prix
coline alors vous vous êtes qui vendre
du coup chacun le rôle de louise louise
thomas 5 1 le rôle de nick à l'école
rôle de mike mike antoine antoine léo et
nicolas alors d'accord et qui qui va
aimer qui
qui va aimer un peu plus et pour le
savez il faut venir dans le souvenir
mois alors vous êtes déjà vous êtes déjà
dont on tourne et ça marche très bien
très très bien vous serez bientôt à
paris
la scène musicale et pour partir en
tournée le 1er octobre à genève le 15
octobre à reims le 10 janvier
[Applaudissements]
à regarder une petite bande annonce
c'est l'événement c'est l'événement de
cet été devait être entre y regarder
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
[Musique]
la scène musicale
on va venir évidemment je veux dire que
le bénin bénin est malade mais n'est pas
été comme ça comme ça
la bnf fardeau pour elle c'est sa
jeunesse son enfance cca naissance c'est
maintenant ces sonates surtout voilà
donc non mais c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui est fou c'est que sardou iplay de
communes comme on dit de cette remise à
temps combien de temps vous avez
travaillé sur le spectacle d'un énorme
casting ses portes vous sortez d'un gros
casting parce que vous êtes tous pas
très connue encore
on a fait pas mal de comédies musicales
ou ou bien on a chacun une carrière solo
on a travaillé dur avant d'arriver sur
ce spectacle
bruno berberes qu'un très grand woods
est à l'origine de ce super caste on a
une grande chance de se rencontrer tous
sur ce projet ça fait un an qu'on
travaille dessus très dur avec serge
denoncourt jouer terran scène est en
fait voilà c'est une aventure qui a
commencé il ya un an et on travaille
encore aujourd allait pourtant je vais
t'aimer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]